joining me now is Ohio Senator JD Vance
um Senator there's an Impulse uh among
some in the Senate uh Republicans
usually to say go get them level them
take them out massive strikes now and I
get that because you know you want to
smash anyone who who harms a single
American but what are we really facing
here well lur we have to remember
there's a big difference between hitting
them back and hitting them back so
aggressively that we invite an
escalation here that could lead to a war
that we're simply not prepared for as a
country the fundamental fact lorea these
guys have got to wake up to is that
America thanks to the decisions that
have been made over 20 30 years but
especially during the Biden
Administration is that we are weaker now
than we have ever been you do not Lumber
into a massive conflict or two or three
conflicts simultaneously when you're at
your low Point what you do Laura is you
smartly rebuild you elect a new
president to replace the disaster that
we have in the white house and then you
project American power from there these
guys have got to remember we do not have
Donald Trump in the Oval Office we have
Joe Biden in the Oval Office and that
means that we have to be cautious about
how we respond to this moment there was
a pentagon briefing today if that's what
you can call it and a reporter actually
asked an important question about the
Secretary of Defense
watch is there any update on whether
secretary Austin will come in talk to us
um sometime soon I don't have a date to
announce certainly aware of the request
and we'll keep you
updated no wonder they didn't miss him
when he was gone for a week I mean it's
just this is
unbelievable just that fact that Austin
cannot stand and answer questions after
we have three Americans dead 40 wounded
and apparently some of them severely
wounded that says it all and Republicans
are like oh go get them Joe what they
can't even answer a question yeah
yeah oh laa it's so absurd and what is
the Secretary of Defense doing is he
able to actually discharge his duties
these are some of the most important
questions that we should be asking Laura
but there is so much going on here how
did we possibly have three Americans
potentially many many more uh who were
at risk on the Jordan Syria border what
were they doing there is it actually
necessary to have them there or are they
Sitting Ducks inviting people or
countries like Iran to come and attack
our people there are just so many
important questions that we're not even
asking and Laura that's what the
supposed to find out right I mean the
you guys are there asite role like I I
would expect the Senate would want to
know what are these bases for are they
really necessary are they advancing
America's interest if so how how much is
it costing can we afford it and how many
more Americans are going to have to die
before we all agree that Biden and his
team are a bunch of
incompetence yeah Laura and there are
about 10 of us that are asking this
question questions and everybody else is
I think is they're living in the past
fundamentally Laura they're living in a
world where America still had the
world's most powerful manufacturing
economy they're living in a world where
we didn't empower the rise of communist
China and they're living in a world
where we have a strong president when in
fact we have the weakest president in an
American generation sitting in the Oval
Office these guys have got to wake up
Lord we've got to rebuild our country
we've got to go back to some common
sense first principles instead what
these guys are doing is pretending
they're living in a world that just
doesn't exist anymore yeah there's a
reason it's called peace through
strength it's not peace through weakness
Eon economic weakness you have to be
strong at home or you're not going to be
able to do much abroad by the way at the
Pentagon yesterday the uh Deputy press
secretary Sabrina Singh was asked
another key
question are you willing to say that the
conflict is no longer contained and it's
spreading I wouldn't say that the
conflict is spreading in that we've seen
enen over 100 attacks on US forces this
attack was certainly escalatory in that
it killed three service members it's not
spreading when troops literally have
died in another country we can't
discount the fact that these attacks are
incredibly dangerous put our service
members at risk but they have not uh up
until yesterday inflicted lethal
harm I mean Senator I I don't even know
what to say about that performance
yesterday but this is Mickey m
Club Laura of course the conflict is
spreading and these people are
completely asleep at the wheel you know
what we haven't talked about Laura the
fact that we Face a massive recruitment
challenge because America's military
leadership is going to war with the
American population culturally we've got
a lot of Crisis Laura it's time to
rebuild it's time to get a new president
yeah that's the only way it's going to
happen Senator thank you hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that not going
to miss any great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on Fox you can get it all here
on YouTube so subscribe right now